hey guys this is andrew from
sharminisenses.com so i've been working
as a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong and i've decided
a few months ago to create
my youtube channel because i want to
show you guys all the different tools
and techniques that i use at work
that work for me to make money on the
markets and
most importantly i will show you how to
do it yourself so basically trading
is about reading the flows analyzing the
data
and to build up our view based on that
technical analysis
is some techniques that look like
drawings but it's actually very
technical like the name is saying that
help us
to read the flows and to find the levels
where you're going to have some
reactions
so today i want to show you how you can
apply all of this
theory to amc let's get into it
[Music]
so this is the amc chart on the four
hours time frame like i
always say guys the fourth time frame is
the best time frame to use where you're
gonna have the best reactions
because this time frame is both used by
short-term investors like day traders
as well as some long-term investors like
institutional clients that are going to
use
the signals provided that they can find
on this time frame
to enter the trades one of the signals
is
the 200 period moving average all right
the simple one arithmetical moving
average
this is something that is very basic
very easy to use and a lot of
institutional clients i know that for
sure are using it
to enter the trades on the imc chart for
hours time frame 200 period moving
average
look what we have so this is my idiot
wave counting let me just
up put it there so this is the 200
moving average
and you can see that here are beautiful
reactions on the 5th of april and
at the end of the week we closed just
under 200 period moving average so for
now it's acting as
support means people like institution
clients all day traders
are actually buying at this levels they
letting some
buying orders at this level and they
just follow
the 200 moving average to keep placing
their orders
if it breaks of course it's not good so
i'm going to make here the different
scenarios
that we have to do that i need to find
some resistance and
support level i just showed you the
support level that is found by the 200
pre-moving average
but if you go on a shorter time in frame
here
on the hourly time frame is just to zoom
in a bit all right
i could use the period moving average as
well on this time frame but like i said
they are not as good signals as on the
longer time frame
and here you can see that i can make a
trend line
just here by connecting the two recent
lows and
surprise it is acting as support as well
here together with the 200 period moving
average on the forward time frame
and here we have this so for now i only
have two
all right but look what is that guys
what is that
and actually i already labeled it abcde
it's a converging triangle so
it's usually appearing in force waves of
idiot wave counting but it can appear in
second waves as well
so that's why i put my counting like
this here we have
one here we are correcting so now that i
have
this triangle that is drawn i can build
up my different scenarios either we
break
so let me go back on the fourth time
frame so either we break the triangle on
the damp side which means we break as
well the 100 moving average and then
we're probably gonna go
to uh revisit the 750 area which
wouldn't be very good because once again
we break this 200
moving average but which would still
look
i mean bullish to me if we don't stay
below it too long
if i go on a daily i send a daily time
frame
we have the 50 moving average that is
at the same level the charge moving
average is very far away once again so
you see the far away is much better
no information to get on the daily time
frame so yeah either we revisit
the 750 area and actually this triangle
would not be a triangle it would be a
zigzag looking like this
this is possible or we break it on the
upside
which for me for now you know most
likely scenario because like i said i
have two buying signals
at the 920 level so it looks to me like
it wants to hold but once again i'm not
sure of that
but if we break it on the upside so if
we trade above 10
at least five hours so we have two
consecutive candles that are
closing above this 10 level
this would mean that we have completed
the second wave
and we are doing the third wave that
would probably lead us
to the 25 level then we would correct
and
might go to the 35 level this is my
longer term view
that i showed you guys already like a
few weeks ago so i'm just you know
trying to make some regular updates
to show you how we adapt if there is
something unexpected that happens
and how we continue to try to predict
what will happen next so that's it for
me i hope you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when
i upload anything new and stay close to
show
i see you guys